tout ça va devenir une plantations
d'huile de palme
oui
[Musique]
réchauffement climatique la planète
s'est donné rendez-vous à la coop 26
donc tu n'es pas mort qu'on combat je
n'ai pas baissé les bras on à l'érosion
dans le cloud et col bateau dans la
sargasse qu'est ce qui nous arrive en
avant partout dans le monde il y a
urgence
ce sont des promesses en l'air ça suffit
franchement ça suffit partout dans le
monde des femmes et des hommes
s'engagent quant à ce qu'on pourra boire
cette eau usée recyclés alors c'est pour
dans deux ans on pourrait nourrir des
milliards de personnes rien qu'avec les
protéines issues de la permaculture
marine ou saas et des pompes à carbonne
et tu vois le résultat on va régler le
problème
avec une programmation exceptionnelle
pour comprendre les enjeux du présent et
les solutions d'avenir la première se
mobilisent pour le climat
[Musique]